In this video we are going to talk about
what is a MAC address. Let me remind you
this has got nothing to do with the Big
Mac or the Mac operating system! Now,
before we get into the details let me
give you an analogy: We have three people
John, Bob, and Mary in a room who want to talk. Now, John, when he wants to talk to
Mary, he says 'Hi, Mary! How are you doing?' Now, when Mary listens to this message,
how does she know that she has to
respond to John? It's through his voice.
So, she replies to John, but not Bob,
saying 'Hey, John! I'm doing good.' Now, if you
have three different computers who want
to talk to each other they don't have
any names, so to bring the analogy of
names and identification to computers we
have this concept of MAC address, which
is unique to each computer's network
interface card.